[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD KASTELEIN: Hi, my name
is Richard Kastelein.
I'm the founder of
hackfest.tv.
And Hackfest has been
a journey for me
of about three years.
I started publishing
Appmarket.tv three years ago,
with the idea of looking into
and examining the media
convergence.
So basically, TV apps,
connected TVs,
smart TV, social TV.
Multi-platform engagement in
transmedia, and how this whole
new eco system is evolving.
One thing led to another.
I never expected to be in
the events business.
But I kept coming across all
these APIs and SDKs.
And I'm like, wow, these
are fantastic.
Developers need to have
more of this stuff.
And I was writing
a lot about it.
And thus the idea for TV
Hackfest was born.
And we did the first show last
year in 2012 in London, along
with Transmedia Fest which was
great, because we had a lot of
creatives and writers
and stuff there.
And this year we've come
to San Francisco.
And we're going to be back in
London again after the summer.
So it was kind of an organic
growth of an idea that just
came together.
My main mission is to bring
together creative writers.
People from the creative
community.
Directors and producers into the
world of technology, and
vice versa.
So they can understand
each other more.
So it's a two way street.
I also see TV as an industry
that's ripe for disruption.
Music.
Print.
I used to be a journalist.
I woke up one morning,
200 million bloggers.
I went to the music industry.
We know what happened there.
I looked at TV and I went,
hmm you know what.
I'm going to keep my
eye out there.
So I started writing about
social TV three years ago--
four years ago now--
which was very early, the
concept of these worlds
meeting on the television
space.
So that's basically the
story behind it.
And we really hope to take the
Hackfest brand, or the
Hackfest experience,
into other cities
next year as well.
This year and next year.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
All right.
So what are you hoping to see
from the contestants today?
RICHARD KASTELEIN: I would
like to see some great
examples of context.
For me, people talk about second
screen and where does
it become useful.
And I don't engage with TV.
And I only email.
And it's true.
The statistics prove it.
Nielsen numbers show that people
aren't engaging with TV
on their second screen.
Even though 88% of tablet owners
use their device while
watching TV once a month.
And they have these phenomenal
numbers and things.
Clearly they aren't
engaging with TV.
I think there needs to be some
exploration of how to make
that marriage work, in terms
of companion experiences.
And I think one of the things
that works really well is game
shows, like "The Million Pound
Drop" in the UK with 100,000
people playing in real time.
But I also think context
is important.
So how many times have you ever
got up from your TV, gone
somewhere, looked--
gone online, sorry, not
gone somewhere--
gone online, looked up IMDb,
gone to Wikimedia, Wikipedia,
find out more information.
I want that information
to be pushed.
I don't want to have
to pull it.
And I want that information
to be pushed to me in an
intelligent, timely manner.
So I think ideas around
context are great.
So TMS is here.
They've got the data.
We've got some great tools
around recognition technology.
So let's see some
mix and match.
And we'll see what
comes out of it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARVIN FERRELL: I've been
writing for RootzWiki for a
very brief period of time now.
But I'm happy to be with them.
Kind of been writing around the
Android community for a
couple years now.
So it's good to see that
going further.
And I took an interest in Google
TV, though I'm not a
developer myself yet, anyway.
I'm at the very cusp of
beginning that process.
I have always been in my writing
career thus far, it's
always been involved with
websites that were
specifically geared toward
Android development and
Android developers.
So at RootzWiki, our readership
is a great deal of
developers themselves, with apps
in the market or on the
RootzWiki forum.
So that's kind of what our
articles are geared towards.
So it's kind of a perfect
opportunity for me to give
them some feedback on my own
user experience with Google TV
since I began using it and
advocate for more development.
Google TV is probably
my favorite Android
device that I own.
I own several Android devices,
and I use Google TV every
single day.
And I have since the
summer of 2011.
So I've got a lot of experience
using it, yeah.
First of all I replaced--
just to go over how I use
Google TV myself.
[INAUDIBLE]
my regular standard stock
launcher with Open Launcher,
by Entertailion.
I also use Netflix
a whole lot.
News Republic, YouTube, Chrome,
Evernote, Dropbox,
Serenity, Plex, Snag, Control.
[INAUDIBLE], Google TV,
remote, able remote.
Chromemote for the Chrome
browser extension.
Various web [INAUDIBLE],
you name it.
Probably share a lot of YouTube
videos from my various
other devices.
That's probably my
favorite featured
ability to share content.
If I'm looking into something,
it's very easy for me to then
transfer that to my
Sony Google TV.
And show other people that
are in the room.
Or have it in a larger format.
So basically from that
standpoint I'm very interested
in seeing Google TV
development grow.
I'm actually a PC developer,
a web developer.
Web designer.
So I don't have a lot of
experience moving into Android
development.
I've done a lot of interviews
with Android
developers over the years.
I'm very connected into the
Android developement
community, I guess.
I can say that.
So I kind of use that as a
segue, maybe getting some of
those guys to bring some
of their stuff
into a Google TV format.
Yeah.
Carmen Delessio, the author of
that book, who I've had the
pleasure of speaking
with a few times.
I originally wrote an article,
because I also volunteer for
another website, Google
TV Friends.
You may have heard of Google
TV Friends as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
absolutely.
MARVIN FERRELL: I write a
few articles over there.
So I got in touch with Carmen
first over there.
And I thought that maybe if I
did something a little more in
depth, a little more hands on,
and kind of even some of that
stuff I'm looking at myself.
Like I said as I'm trying to
get into development for
Google TV specifically.
So I thought that it was good
to share that with other
people, especially developers
who are already established
and out there.
And maybe get some attention
towards some of the features
and things I would like to
see added to Google TV.
MALE SPEAKER: So what would
those features be?
MARVIN FERRELL: Most of these
things are things that I think
the development community, not
Google specifically, are
better positioned to bring us
in the way that I'd like to
see it, I guess.
In the community we would love
to see some better Google
support, a dedicated
Gmail app.
Google docs.
More launchers.
Some of the existing launchers
on the small Android screen
are fabulous.
I would like to see some of the
innovation brought to the
big screen.
As a matter of fact, I'm working
on an article right
now that's really basically
finished, it will probably
publish soon, about Google TV
launchers specifically.
And how we would like to see
some of the creative ideas
that have been brought to the
Android small screen in terms
of launchers, and how much
better the performance some
developers can tend to squeeze
out of the launcher.
In particular I cite Open
Launcher, which is currently,
as you may well know, another
launcher that is available for
Google TV, that really
brings some
features, an easier layout.
I'll cite an example
for Open Launcher.
My wife uses Android a lot.
Android tablet.
She uses her Android
tablet, 10" tablet.
It's her favorite thing.
For her, Open Launcher was a
little bit easier to grasp.
It reminded her more of the
Android experience that she
was already used to.
So seeing some more of that
kind of thing brought to
Google TV, because the creative
level that they take
in, they launch it on the small
screen, it's really nice.
I think some of that could be
replicated on the big screen.
Mostly, I think they haven't
even considered it.
So that's where I'm trying
to start it.
I'm trying to get more of them
to consider Google TV
development.
I'd like to see them
consider it as a
lucrative thing as well.
I mean there are legions of
Google TV fans that are just
waiting for some of these apps
to be made available on the
big screen.
And we'll buy them.
And that's kind of the point
that I'm getting at.
So just to get them to even
consider Google TV development
as an option, as an option for
even more revenue, is more
what I'm trying to
get out there.
And I think that's
what they do.
I think a lot of developers
don't even give Google TV a
thought as they produce
apps for the tablet
and smartphone formats.
So what I've tried to do with
my advocacy for Google TV is
kind of share my user
experience.
I have about maybe 3,700
followers on Google+.
And I try to let them know how
Google TV makes my day a
little bit brighter sometimes.
It's a remarkable platform,
how it's developed.
I'd like to see it
go a lot further.
But I think what's missing is
that the people don't really
understand a lot.
A lot of people haven't touched
smart TVs as yet.
So they get to understand that
Google TV is how much it's
like Android and how many things
you can do with it.
In the article I've cited an
example of my brother who
already owns a Sony Google TV,
but he purchased a Roku box.
Mostly because he thought
he would get some more
hackability out of it.
And he came to the conclusion
that his Google TV was a lot
more versatile than
he thought.
So that's kind of what I think
is lacking, basically letting
the Android user-- because
there are a lot of us out
there who use Android
and we love it
and we swear by Android--
to get that same kind of energy
behind Google TV by
showing people that hey, it's
not that much different from
your tablet or smartphone.
That's kind of where I think
we're missing it.
So just kind of pushing the
format, letting people know it
is Android at its core.
And it works basically
the same.
And some of the versatility that
you can get out of it.
It's interesting that you bring
up the SDK because in
another article that I wrote
recently on Google TV Friends,
specifically about Google TV
development, the focus of the
article is on some of the
changes you have made to the
SDK and kind of advanced it and
make it more accessible
for those other platforms.
Apple and Linux, specifically.
So it's interesting that
you bring that up.
I think I'd heard it was a
hurdle when they were trying
to, I don't know, something
with video playback or
something like that.
That a lot of developers were
looking for the emulator to be
more functional for that.
But I'm not sure because I'm not
really well versed in the
intricacies of what some of
the problems people were
having with the emulator were.
But getting the word out there
that, like you said, it's just
as approachable as developing an
app for Android on any size
or scale, is important.
And I think that's
lacking as well.
And I see that as a hurdle for
Google TV to overcome.
Other than that, there's some
different devices too.
I think for Google TV, when
Android first began it had
that same hurdle to leap.
It's kind of the fragmentation
between devices.
And different devices delivered
different levels of
performance.
So you may have been an early
adopter who had a bad
experience.
And now that Google TV has come
a long way, you're not
really aware of the progress
that has been made.
So you kind of have a bad
taste in your mouth.
And trying to get people to
overcome that is something
that I think needs to be done.
Because Google TV is a
lot different now.
It's a lot better.
It's a lot faster and more
usable now than when I first
bought a Google TV.
MALE SPEAKER: Which one
is your first one?
MARVIN FERRELL: Actually I'm
using the same one that I
initially bought.
But the Honeycomb updates is
where I saw a turn around in
where I wanted it to go.
It started to look more like
I wanted it to look.
It started becoming a platform
that was easier for me to use
on a daily basis.
Also the extension of my
other Android devices.
This is important.
This is something I
think is lacking.
My Nexus 7 actually makes my
Google TV far more usable,
than the, for example the remote
control that came stock
with my TV.
Let me see if I can show you.
This deal.
MALE SPEAKER: Mm-hmm.
MARVIN FERRELL: Here.
Not very user friendly.
But Google TV remote or able
remote, a third party app.
Those two, like I said, my
family members primarily use
those now to control the TV.
I mean it's just a
lot easier to do.
And I think that we should
showcase that a little more.
And that's one thing I want
to do at RootzWiki.
In my case, I have
several TVs.
The Google TV is kind
of my device.
It's kind of an extension of
my Android collection until
it's time for Netflix or
something like that.
So for me, I'm more of a
hardcore Google TV user.
I use things like Evernote,
Dropbox, sideload apps and
things of that nature.
This point you were making
about second screen apps.
And that's kind of another big
deal that I've been speaking
out a lot about, because I like
what I've seen in the
early iterations of what
second screen apps were
looking like on Google TV.
I mentioned, when you asked me
what apps I like to use, I
mentioned Control TV which has a
trivia game and a poker game
that use your Android device.
Your poker hand is displayed
on your Android device.
Everybody has a key.
This is for people out there who
aren't familiar with it.
Everybody enters a key and
their Android device
interfaces with the
television.
Essentially the television
is the dealer.
Now see that's an experience
that I'd like to see more of.
It's a really, really great use
of the second screen app.
And it's a great use of Google
TV, as a gaming platform.
Kind of a group experience.
And I really, really,
really enjoy that.
Let's Draw is another one, that
kind of uses the tablet
or smartphone as a second
screen or controller.
Sony has an app that they make,
that they also put out.
It's basically just called
Smart TV remote.
It has an on screen controller
on it that can be used across
other Google TV apps as well.
So more things of that nature,
that make input and control a
little bit easier.
And also augment our
television watching
experience.
Like I'm surprised that I
haven't seen GetGlue.
This is a social network
that I've been a part
of for a long time.
GetGlue is basically just about
earning achievements.
They hand out these stickers for
checking in to programs or
books that you're reading.
Or games that you're playing.
You see that's an opportunity,
I think, that a lot of the
established brands
are missing.
Because GetGlue could
be right in there.
I could share it when I'm
watching from my TV screen.
I could have that conversation
that I'm having on GetGlue on
my Nexus 7, with the person on
my TV instead of having to use
a second Android device.
And I just think that some of
the opportunities for Google
TV haven't caught on yet.
And I'd like to see
more of it.
I think we've basically got the
grasp of what we're trying
to do over at RootzWiki.
What we're working on right now,
just far as the future of
RootzWiki is concerned,
is a Google TV forum.
A dedicated Google TV forum
is in the works.
So I'm not sure where we are
along the process of
getting that done.
But we'll be sharing that.
And then if people know about
that as soon as we get it up,
and we would like to have some
feedback from you guys.
Or any other developers
out there.
Because RootzWiki is kind of
what's a developer community.
So it's already going
on our RootzWiki.
So we hope to be able to
generate some excitement
through that kind of
thing on there.
And of course I'll be writing
more articles about Google TV
in the near future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Hello everyone.
In this episode, we are going
to talk about Google Play.
And how you get your
applications for Google TV
into the Google Play store.
So let's take a look.
There is a lot of documentation
on how to
publish Android applications.
So keep in mind Google TV,
it's an Android device.
So all of the Android guidelines
apply just as well
as for all the mobile
and tablet devices.
So take a look online on
developer.android.com.
There is a lot of good
information about how to
publish your application.
So first, of course, you
have to test your app.
We assume you have developed
it and tested it for this
episode here.
And we will talk a little bit
about some of the things that
are unique to Google TV.
I'll get to that in a while.
So one of the differences of
Google TV, and a lot of the
other standard Android devices,
is some of the
compatibility features
that it supports.
Naturally a television is a very
different device from a
mobile phone.
The biggest difference, of
course, is it does not have a
touch screen.
I'll show you that
in a little bit.
If you choose to have multiple
APKs for the same application,
think about how this
impacts your
strategy in terms of pricing.
Is your mobile app going to be
the same price as your TV app?
Or maybe there's different
features.
So that's another thing
to keep in mind.
Lastly, make sure you have
promotional graphics that of
course reflect your TV app.
And make sure your APK
is ready for release.
So let's look at what it takes
to get your APK ready to be
released on Play store.
Again follow the Android
documentation.
There is a really great
checklist that walks you
through all of the steps.
Probably one of the first things
you want to do if you
have not already published
Android applications in the
Play store, is you want to
create a cryptographic key
which allows you to sign
your application.
Make sure you have a key that
you can keep for a long time.
The key must be valid
until at least 2033.
And make sure you keep
that key safe.
You will need that key every
time you update your
application in the future.
OK let's look at how the Play
store chooses which
applications are available
on Google TV.
So the filtering is strictly
based on Android features.
So as I've mentioned earlier,
the big difference between a
mobile device and the Google TV
is that Google TV is not a
touchscreen device.
So make sure when you declare
your manifest file, you add
the users feature Android
hardware touch screen, and
make it required equals false.
By the way, this will not filter
out your application
from regular, normal mobile
devices with a touch screen.
It will only allow
it to also run on
non-touch screen devices.
If you want to run on only the
Google TV, then you can
specify a separate feature
which is the
com.google.android.tv feature.
Also make sure you have the
right min SDK and max SDK
version set.
We recommend a target
SDK of 12 or 13.
Google TV currently, the version
that's most in the
market is API version 13.
OK.
Now let's take a look at what
it takes to get your
application tested
on Google TV.
So first you need to connect ADB
to your Google TV device.
On a regular Android mobile
device you would just plug-in
your USB cable.
On Google TV we use
IP addresses.
So you type adb connect and the
IP address of your device.
As you can see, once you've done
this ADB recognizes your
Google TV as just another
Android device.
And you can use all the
regular ADB commands.
Things like adb shell, adb
logcat, adb install.
All the ADB commands you know
and love from your Android
development.
One other thing when you use adb
logcat, take a look at the
logs of your application.
Before you publish your
application, you want to make
sure you clean up a lot of the
log and debugging messages
that may be in your app.
So after you have connected
ADB you can see in Eclipse
IDE, you can actually access
your adb logcat
from within the IDE.
And you can also do things like
run or debug directly on
your Google TV device
from Eclipse.
Let's take a quick
look at that.
So just for an example, I've
set a break point here.
And let's go and debug
this application
with this break point.
As you see in the console, it
is connecting to the device
waiting for the debugger.
And now things are
starting up here.
And when we change to the debug
perspective, you can see
we see the Dalvik
virtual machine.
And we see threads running.
And after awhile your
application started up and it
has hit the break point.
Now what you can do is,
you can just single
step through it.
You can watch your variables.
It's a great tool to verify
your application.
You can also check things
like CPU load or memory.
Or my favorite, take
a screenshot.
This screenshot comes in very
handy later on when you upload
your application to the
Android Play store.
You should actually use the
screenshots from Google TV.
Make sure you scale them
to 1280 by 720 pixels.
So you get great, good looking
screenshots on Play
store for Google TV.
Now let's take a look at
the manifest file.
The manifest file is really the
one place where a lot of
the features are kept that
influence how your application
is filtered on the Play store.
So before you upload, make
sure your version
code is up to date.
You have to increment your
version code when you upload a
new version to the Google
Play store.
The version name is the
human readable form.
You can enter a string
or a more
explanatory version number.
The key feature is really
Android hardware touch screen.
If you are developing for Google
TV, make sure to set
the touch screen as required
equals false.
The other feature is the
com.google.adroid.tv.
You can set that to true or
false, depending if you want
your application to be exclusive
for Google TV.
Take a look at the
support screen.
Make sure you support at least
normal and large screens for
your application.
Normal is for 720p.
Large screens is for 1080p.
So when we look at the manifest
XML, it's always a
good idea to double
check the XML.
Make sure everything is
the way you like it.
By the way, here you
see the target SDK
version I've set to 13.
And the minimum to 12, which
should cover all of the Google
TV devices.
And here we see the
features for touch
screen and Android TV.
So one of the property I want
to point out is the Android
package name.
Make sure it is a meaningful
and unique package name for
your application.
We recommend that you start
with something like your
domain name or your
company name.
And keep in mind this package
name is unique to your
application.
And it will stay with your
application for its entire
life in the Google Play store.
One other thing is, make sure
you turn off debugging mode.
You want to turn this off.
And on a real application when
you release it to market, you
may also want to obfuscate
it using tools like,
for example, ProGuard.
During the development process,
your application gets
typically signed with
a debug key.
Now when you get ready to
publish in the Play store, you
want to sign it with an
actual release key.
So how can you do that?
In Eclipse, you click on the
project and then you look at
the Android tools
and use export
signed application package.
This will create a file that is
ready to be uploaded to the
Google Play store.
So choose the correct project,
and then go and choose a key
store that you want to use
to actually sign this
application.
Please make sure you keep a copy
and a backup of this key
store for future use.
You will need the same key store
every time you update
your application in the
Google Play store.
So it's very important to
keep this backed up.
Now choose the proper key.
Enter the password again.
And this will create these
signed package for the upload
to the Google Play Store.
You want to double check the
certificate is valid until at
least 2033.
And make sure all the
information is correct in the
certificate.
OK now that we have exported the
APK, let's take a look and
verify if all the settings
are indeed correct.
The tool to use for this
is called AAPT.
It's the Android Application
Packaging Tool.
And you can use the parameters
dump badging.
And your APK name.
This will show you all of the
features and permissions, and
all of the meta information
in a very simple,
user, readable form.
Take a look at the version
code, the target SDK.
And especially double check
that the Android hardware
touch screen is listed
as not required.
Also take a look at the icons
that you package with your
application.
You want to make sure you have
at least the 240 and the 320
dpi resolution icons, to make
sure it looks really brilliant
and sharp on a large
television screen.
The other thing to verify
is you can use the tool
jarsigner, and you can verify
the certificates that have
been used to sign your
application with.
It's just a good idea to make
sure everything looks good.
In this case, we see that
the certificate used.
It uses my name, it uses
my organization.
Things look pretty good.
And the expiration date
is in the future.
In this case it's 2036.
Once you're ready to upload
to Google Play, go to the
play.google.com/apps/publish
developer console.
In the developer console
you'll see a list of
applications which you own,
or which you have
uploaded in the past.
And you can take a look
at the store listing.
It will show you things like
the title, the description,
the featured image.
And so on and so forth.
It's a good idea to update some
of the information, some
of the description.
Update maybe the
release notes.
And update the recent changes.
So your users know what
is new in this update.
Now let's look at the APKs.
When you click on APKs,
I suggest choosing
the advanced mode.
This gives you a little bit more
features and a little bit
more flexibility.
And you can upload a APK.
And you can simply browse,
select the file we just
created, upload it.
And the Google Play store
gives you a high level
overview of what are the
features of your application.
What are some of the required
permissions.
And it also gives you a list of
devices that are available
for your application.
So just give it a look.
Make sure it looks good to you,
and then save the file.
The file is not active.
So it's not yet being pushed
out to developers.
So you have a chance
to double check.
You also can upload
this in advance.
You can stage it.
And then at a given time,
whenever you're ready, you can
publish the application
to your users.
So now I can either
reset my draft,
re-upload a new version.
Or if I'm happy with the version
I uploaded, I can
publish this version
with one click.
Now the application is being
published and is available
through Google Play to
Google TV devices.
Please be patient.
The updating of all the back
end servers, it may take a
couple minutes to
a couple hours.
So it may take a few
minutes for your
changes to actually appear.
Another feature I want to
highlight is the statistics.
So as an application developer,
you're always
interested who is
using your app.
How many people are
using your app?
Which versions?
Which countries?
Which devices?
So our statistics page gives
you a very good overview of
the breakdown of
your customers.
Great.
Now your app is uploaded
to the Play store.
The last and final check is you
can go to play.google.com,
and you can check out your
listing in the Play store.
As I said earlier, give
it a few minutes.
If your listing does not update
immediately, it can
take a little while.
It can take up to one
or two hours.
So take a look, check it out.
Verify, especially the quality
of your screenshots and the
quality of your graphics.
And lastly, let us
know about it.
Google TV is a great platform
to develop for, and we're
always excited for
new applications.
And we're always looking forward
to hearing from you
guys about what new apps you
have come up with that
run on Google TV.
So let us know in
our Plus page.
And I hope you guys have a
great week, and looking
forward to seeing all those
new applications.
Thanks a lot and see
you next time.